all right Dave Jewett you and I recently
got to see about two hours of baldur's
gate 3 the upcoming highly anticipated C
RPG from Larian studios the developers
of divinity original sin 1 and 2 and
yeah we got to sit down and see a decent
amount of it we didn't have hands on but
spend vinca the creative director played
it for us and showed us a few different
scenarios and there's a lot to unpack
here so we'll do our best to keep it
brief but you strike me as more of a
baldur's gate and like Dungeons &
Dragons expert than I am so my thing I
want to talk to you first about before
we get into the Nitty Gritty is like
kind of flesh out the context of this
game in terms of like Baldur's Gate 1 &
2 and the legacy that's kind of leading
up to this point and why it is such a
big deal even if you didn't really play
any of Larry ins other games yeah I mean
it's been over a decade was even like a
cilium at years since bolas gate 1 & 2
and they were really kind of
groundbreaking when it came to the CIC
RPG genre back then it's it's a very
strange like choice to continue from
such an old series I think but because
that's it's a series that so many people
grew up with and have such like an
affinity with even if you've never
played it you've probably heard boulders
gates from someone like the console
adaptations or
even original or even if you've never
played any of the the actual video games
if you're a longtime D&D player it's
probably something that's popped up in
the law so it's I think's grounding
their game quite a lot for new
generations yeah it's almost as if and I
got to talk to spend vinca the creative
director afterward in an interview and
we have that interview transcribed on
GameSpot if people wanna go check that
out if you're watching this on youtube
or wherever and I was asking I was like
to me divinity original sin - despite
not pulling from dungeon to drag its
lore was the closest a video game has
ever gotten to emulating Dungeons &
Dragons so it's almost like yeah why do
this if you didn't really need to but
again it's baldur's gate and like you
said there is this nostalgia attached to
it there is this legacy and respect
attached to it and they've been wanting
to do this since after they made
divinity original sin 1 and then I think
like toward the end of development on
divinity version 2 Wizards of the coast
had
Sven and said all right you got the
green light we'd like your games let's
talk more about this so that's what I
want to talk about is if you've played
dos 1 and 2 and you're coming into
baldur's gate 3 later this year what
sets this apart based on the demo we saw
from dos - I think like if you if you
look at some of the the new game players
coming out aesthetically it does look
very similar but I think the way that
they're a building your character and
allowing your character to interact with
the world is much deeper now you see
like some of the arch characters
building high ground with some of us
like boxes and debris that's really
clever wrinkle having take taking like
bonus actions from D&D and applying them
in a different way to baldur's gate 3 to
allow you to move attack do things like
shove pass on items there was a moment
in in the demo that we had because the
random nature in the in the of the game
we probably had vastly different demos
but when we when Simone was showing off
the game the combat let's say was not
going his way
so through like a desperate attempt to
do some damage he took off his
characters boots and threw them at the
enemy which is it's like it's such a
bizarre wrinkle that has only previously
been able to you can only do that in
your imagination right I was talking to
some of the guys afterwards and they
were saying that if your character is
strong enough or you've got like a gnome
companion you can throw your companions
just the the added interactivity between
very like my new elements of the game is
it was pretty staggering to see and it's
going to be incredible to see how broken
and how weird you can get with kind of
the layers of agency with this game yeah
because that's what das2 was kind of
known for right was like what can't you
do in this game and there wasn't much
you know and again based on this demo it
was fun to hear again like who knows how
much was rehearsed I mean I know they
rehearsed for it but like who knows how
much was organic and how much was like
this magic button that the devs were
pressing regardless it was still super
exciting to see how when things went
right yeah but more exciting was when
things went wrong and how he adapted
like you said he through
boots or in another case like one of the
characters got down across the map and
he had kind of been solo so he had to
get his other party members come back to
their body put out this like grease fire
that was surrounding them and then this
was all just to get this amulet that
would be so kind of useful later for a
sidequest and also going back to the
more Bioware roots they have a cinematic
camera now
he played das2 it never really left the
isometric view most of the time if you
had a conversation with other character
it would just kind of still say and
hover above you you'd see text box how
did the cinematic camera effect you know
like the game from what we saw in your
opinion it's I feel like it's going to
add a lot of you know intimacy in
connection to the characters which stops
extremely important when it comes to D&D
you get so close to those characters
because chance because you've made them
yourself right and adding that layer
especially when it comes to trying weird
things when it comes to you know
charisma or or any of your stats and
dice rolling seeing that actually happen
on the faces and attitudes of each
character is really interesting and
seeing how you know some of the
decisions you're going to make is going
to affect those relationships because
they've obviously keen to add in pieces
like that that there will be kind of
relationships and connections of these
characters being built which again is
super intriguing because I think
divinity was kind of light on that there
was you you could get closer to some of
these companions but it seems that the
options you can get of exploring the the
your party members is has just been
dialed up again yeah in terms of party
members in composition let's get into
the combat because again that's another
thing that Larian was saying when they
first announced the game they're like
this was a bit you know it was a bit of
an obstacle right because we had to
adapt the D&D fifth rule set which is
the which i think is pretty widely
enjoyed just because of how streamlined
it is so they were trying to think of
how to bring that over to a video game
and you know they've been good about
taking tabletop RPG mechanics in the
past and making it into a video game but
here they are heavily relying on the
idea of the the 20-sided dice roll and
how that will play into you know like if
your character meets a certain
perception check or if your character
needs a certain charisma check to
or you know like persuasion check to you
know like would we which we've seen in
other games but in combat it seemed to
really be taking effect because
obviously dose two didn't really have
classes right so they're going back to a
more traditional RPG classes here based
on the combat I want to talk about the
verticality and how did the turn-based
nature of like setting up a fight in an
ambush but first off what were your
initial impressions of the combat based
on what Sven was playing at first I will
admit I thought this looks this just
looks like dust ooh and then as he
started playing more and more you can
start to see different wrinkles in the
game you can see that decisions seemed a
lot more important things like high
ground the composition of your team what
abilities you're using because again
it's got the DND thing of having to rest
to be able to use many spells a day and
then there was they were touching on the
fact that you could be turn base and
live at the same time so you're some of
your party members could be away doing
one thing some of your party members
could be actually be engaged in combat
but the one thing I'm glad that they've
not really tapped too much into
something that dose two was known for it
was always like kind of an inside joke
people that play the game is
everything's on fire all the time that
whole kind of element mixing together
was such a huge part now some of that
from what we've seen is still in there
like throwing grease flasks and oil and
setting them on fire and being able to
put fires out with rain and make steam
but from what I can see they've dialed
that down quite a bit which I'm really
happy for because I didn't want that to
kind of overtake the the wider
decision-making and really niche options
that had kind of having a D&D background
was was gonna give it and that's not to
say that they like just ditched all the
complexity right they might have made it
a little less like hectic in terms of
what's on fire but now they're kind of
making more use of light and dark which
you know like kind of goes back to like
a Dungeons & Dragons campaign which
plays heavily into stealth and you kind
of mentioned if you're near a fight
whether you're with all your characters
or if you're sending one of your
characters like Sven sent a star in the
vampire character his his main character
around up this cliff to get behind this
Archer that he had seen up above them
which again in this game verticality and
advantage is huge and they're trying to
figure out how to earn there they're
working on bringing that idea of
advantage from the tabletop game into
this game and a lot of it has to do with
verticality and classes like you
mentioned but he sent his protagonist
into a turn-based mode before the actual
combat had started which allowed him to
like sneak up behind him without like
just triggering it and having him ready
to attack the archer from behind while
everybody else down below actually
initiated the fight it's a bit hard to
describe unless you see it but it worked
out pretty elegantly if you are someone
who really likes to micromanage
everything and ensure that this this
ambushes gonna go off without a hitch
there will be a hitch knowing these
games but it works out pretty well
because you know his character was able
to shove the archer off the ledge and
then he had the high ground and that
Archer was kind of knocked out for a
while
but I do also want to talk about the
fact that yes they're doing multiplayer
again and dust2 was you know like boss
two is a great multiplayer experience
because you could each pick a character
and play them however you want and
obviously like you it was very much
about living with the consequences of
your choices and there wasn't really you
know like there wasn't tethering and
they're bringing that into Baldur's Gate
3 and you know that's providing a lot of
challenges but that's here did you are
you like someone who will play
multiplayer or really you stick to it
more solo or what's your usual go-to if
it's anything like those two I'll play
through most of it solo but there are
moments in in that game where I went I
dipped into multiplayer and I think this
one especially I'd be more attracted to
it because Dungeons & Dragons at the
core is such kind of a social you know
multi person thing and the ability to go
and go anywhere
really else you want in the world alone
have your own little mini adventure use
some of the kind of agency that's
available to you to to get certain items
to overcome certain obstacles and then
kind of come back together to your party
mates I think that's going to add a lot
of really interesting kind of those
water-cooler moments or even within your
own parties and I I just went to the
city of Boulder and and got all this all
these swords and now I'm turning back up
to my friends camp and everyone's fully
equipped like it doesn't it doesn't feel
like you need to be playing kind of
either like on discord at the same time
you can
have your little adventure and link
together again which i think is also a
really cool kind of way of soft
implementing that social aspect it means
that you can play multiplayer without I
suppose all having kind of the same we
need to set aside four hours to have
this session yeah and obviously like a
big part of what Larry and I was just
trying to play DM except like millions
of people at a time with the game so I
guess unless there's anything else you
wanted to touch to touch on I think we
could kind of wrap up because you know
people have been watching gameplay and
again we have an interview with Sven
vinca that I did that's over on GameSpot
if you're watching this video it's
probably below this video but again
there will be more about bulge gate
coming out soon they are gonna do an
early access period they're not being
concrete on how exactly they're gonna
handle it they did say they'll you know
they'll release some content at first
highly highly doubt it'll be the whole
game just with one character or
something like that it'll probably be
like earlier content with several
different characters and bills that you
could try out again they didn't specify
but that they told me that's the kind of
the avenue they're gonna consider but
yeah baldur's gate 3 from Larian studios
developers of original divinity original
sin 2 if you're waiting for baldur's
gate 3 and you are kind of super into
this CRPG renaissance so to speak that's
been happening the last few years go
play divinity original sin 2 and then if
you've played that and haven't played
one go play one but Dave do it thank you
so much for joining nothing here again
if you want to see more about baldur's
gate 3 over to GameSpot and also if you
want to take a closer look at the
cinematic that was released alongside
all the gameplay Dave is doing a
breakdown of that trailer and using all
of his Dungeons and Dragons nerd lore
and he's gonna apply that to figure out
exactly what part of the massive D&D
lore universe Boulder's day 3 will be
pulling from
[Music]